[MUSIC PLAYING]
FELD: Good morning.
Did everybody have a good
breakfast this morning?
[INAUDIBLE]
Okay.
I have two announcements first.
First of all, we have a
handout on the physics
of karate, which is going to be
the subject of today's lecture.
Would everybody
please settle down?
The second thing
is that many people
have come to Professor Redwine
and myself with the freshman
evaluation forms.
These forms should be brought
to your recitation section.
They should not
be brought to us.
So you hand them in to
your recitation instructor.
So today, we have a
special discussion
of some applications of Newton's
laws to the physics of karate--
to karate.
And I hope everybody--
will everybody
please sit down quickly
and take your seats?
This will be-- everybody
get settled, please.
So karate is an art, a sport,
and it requires demonstrations.
And so I've asked a couple of
colleagues to join me here.
And I would like to
introduce my colleagues now.
Come on out.
Sir--
[APPLAUSE]
This is David Feld, Alexandra
Feld, and Jonathan Feld--
just a coincidence.
Now, karate is something
which everybody knows about.
One knows about the oriental
connections with it.
People have seen
these demonstrations
in which fabulous piles of
bricks and blocks of concrete
are demolished with a hand.
And there's a lot of physics
involved in that process.
After all, how is it
that a piece of bone
can break a piece of
concrete and not the reverse?
It has to do with Newton's laws.
It has to do with
our understanding
of various concepts of
physics and mechanics.
And one of the
extraordinary things
is that the ancient oriental
masters who studied karate
as far as 2,000 years ago knew
these secrets, even though they
didn't know Newton's laws.
And I could tell you that if
you study the motions which
have been developed in
karate, if you study
the various techniques
which have been developed,
you find that they really use
Newton's laws and the laws
of mechanics in
very special ways
to make nearly optimal
use of the human body.
Now may I have the
first slide, please?
I guess I can
control these myself.
I tried to have some slides
today, because there's
a lot of material to present.
And I want to be sure
I have time to do that.
First, I want to say that
this lecture is dedicated
to the memory of Ron McNair,
our karate instructor
and a graduate of MIT.
May I have the
next slide, please?
Oh, I guess I can
do this myself.
Forward.
Now the knowledge of
karate and the knowledge
of the Asian fighting
arts was actually
also known in the West.
And here's a picture
from the Vatican
Museum of two Greek wrestlers
Kruegas and Damoxenos
And this was a story
which goes back to 400 BC.
And actually, according
to the legend,
Kruegas and Damoxenos
were two great fighters
who wrestled with one another.
And they wrestled
all day and all night
to see who would be the best.
And neither could
beat the other.
And so finally, they
decided that they
would have a contest
with each delivering
one blow to the other.
So first, Kruegas elected
to give a very hard blow
to Damoxenos' head, which
he managed to withstand.
And then Damoxenos then asked
Kruegas to raise his arm.
And you can see here
the point of this story
is the very fine
spear-hand strike, which
was then delivered.
And without going into the
anatomical problems which
followed, suffice to say that
Kruegas came out the victor.
I will eliminate some of the
more gory aspects of the story.
Now let's see here.
Next slide, please.
I don't seem to be
able to control this.
That's all for the
slides for now.
Now we want to tell you
about the physics of karate.
And we want to tell you a
little bit about karate itself.
And we want to
tell you something
about the philosophy
of karate, also.
As I mentioned, karate
is an Asian oriental art.
It's practiced in all the
different countries of Asia.
Its roots go back
2,000 years or more.
And modern karate-- the word
"karate" means "empty hand"--
was a form of
weaponless fighting
which was developed in
the island of Okinawa
in the 17th century, when the
Japanese took over that island
and prevented the soldiers
and people of Okinawa
from practicing
their feudal combats.
And so they developed
this technique
of fighting without weapons.
It then was transferred to
Japan in the early 1900s,
and has become
very popular today.
Karate is a purely defensive
sport and a defensive art.
It is not something which
is developed so that you
go out and beat people up.
And as you will see, I
will try to emphasize
in various points
of this lecture
the very defensive
nature of karate.
And I also want to say
that karate is also
very important for developing
mental concentration, as well
as physical strength.
And the mental
discipline in karate
is at least as important as
the physical aspects of it.
So what we're going
to do in this lecture
is I want to show you some
of the basic techniques.
I then want to show you
something very interesting--
the central part of karate
which are called Kata.
They're very beautiful, little
dances, kinds of dances.
We'll get into that.
Then we'll discuss the theory
and experimental aspects
of breaking and
some other things.
So let us begin now
by demonstrating
some of the basic techniques
with David and Jonathan.
So now--
FELD: Rei.
FELD: Now the
elements of karate,
just like the
elements of physics,
are very well defined
and very well focused.
And there are many, many basic
techniques, 70 or 80 of them.
Hand techniques,
foot techniques,
head techniques--
any part of the body
can be used as a
weapon, but it's always
used in a very special way.
The most basic
technique in karate
is the front forward
punch, the Seiken Zuki.
Now, this really
illustrates many things
about a typical
karate technique.
The first thing is
that karate is totally
different from Western sports.
You know how we have
all this follow through,
and these wide swings,
and so forth, and so on.
Karate is completely
the opposite.
The ancient masters discovered
that the most important concept
was focus.
In each karate technique, the
idea is to develop the largest
amount of velocity, the
largest amount of force,
and the largest
amount of momentum--
something that we just started
talking about in the last
lecture--
to be able as
quickly as possible
to deliver a high amount
of kinetic energy,
and then to transfer
it to the target.
Okay, let's demonstrate
that at full speed.
FELD: [SHOUTS]
FELD: All right.
Now, not only are
there karate strikes,
but there are also blocks
for each technique.
And the blocks are done
in a very economical way.
So now let us demonstrate how
this kind of a Seiken Zuki--
oh, yeah, do you want
to do it to the face?
Demonstrate to the face.
Go ahead.
FELD: [SHOUTS]
FELD: I should also mention
that black belts like this
are very precise in
their techniques.
And it's expected that when
demonstrations like this occur,
that there is just paper-thin
precision in all of the moves.
So let's demonstrate
some blocks and counters.
This is going to be some
sort of an upper block.
Go ahead.
FELD:
[VOCALIZING WITH EACH PUNCH]
FELD: So notice, here's
a typical example
where instead of meeting
force with force head on,
what happens is a certain
amount of transverse force
and transverse
momentum is delivered
to simply redirect the
technique and render
it harmless to the opponent.
Now Jonathan is going to
demonstrate another technique,
a hammer fist.
This is a technique which is
very effective in breaking
piles of concrete.
And David will show a
typical block for that.
Go ahead.
FELD:
[VOCALIZING WITH EACH PUNCH]
FELD: Now, there are
many, many other kinds
of karate techniques.
And I want to emphasize that
all of the parts of the body
are used in these techniques.
Let us just show you
one-- no, no, one kick.
This is a typical karate kick.
It's called the
sidekick, the Yoko Gari.
Go ahead.
Now you can see
here, it's delivered
with the knife part of the--
hello-- it's delivered with
the knife part of the foot
to minimize the contact area.
And the toes are
curled to prevent them
from being broken
off in the technique.
And there's a very large
amount of energy and power
which can be delivered
in this technique.
Go ahead.
FELD: [VOCALIZING]
FELD: Thank you very much.
Now let me show--
[APPLAUSE]
Now I'd like to show some slides
of some physical measurements
that we've done over the
years to be able to study
some of these things.
And this is actually a strobe
movie that we made where each
of these techniques--
this is a Seiken Zuki--
and each of these techniques
was taken one millisecond apart.
And then by just
studying the position,
we could study the velocity
as a function of time.
And you can see that in
this particular technique,
for example, the velocity rose.
Here's the focus.
Remember, I told you
it is very focused.
The velocity is
maximum at this point.
And when the distance
got to be about 85%
of the way to the
target, the velocity
was around 7 and 1/2
meters per second.
And the mass of a
fist is typically
of the order of 1
kilogram, so that
means 1/2 mV squared would
be 1/2 times 1 times 100,
or say 50 joules.
So 50 joules of energy
is being delivered
in a time of maybe a tenth of
a second or a few hundredths
a second.
So that's maybe 500
watts of power, which is
an interesting amount of power.
It doesn't sound like a lot of
power, but on the other hand
it's certainly enough to
break huge pieces of concrete.
Next slide, please.
I can't control this.
This is a hammer
fist-- the same thing.
Here, we see velocities of the
order of 10 meters per second.
Next, please.
These are, again, strobe movies.
And here's just an example
of an expert karate expert.
Notice with a kick,
you get of the order
of 10 to 15 meters per second,
with various kinds of strikes,
10 to 15 meters per second,
and so forth, and so on.
So that gives us now a
good piece of information
as to how much speed and how
much energy can be delivered
in a karate technique.
Next slide, please.
Good, good, shut them off now.
Thank you.
Now the next thing
is I would like
to get right into
this most central
and to me, the most
interesting aspect of karate--
the kata.
And these kata are very,
very wonderful things.
They are very much
like classical ballet.
They are prescribed
sets of movements
in which the karate practitioner
fights an imaginary series
of opponents.
And there are only a
limited number of kata.
For example, in
the Shotokan style
of karate, which is the one that
we'll be demonstrating today,
there are about 50 kata.
And each one of them has to
be done in a very special way.
There's the same
kind of perfection.
It's very, very closely
related to ballet, I find.
And in doing these, you're
really never competing
with anyone except yourself.
And one can spend
one's whole lifetime
just constantly trying
to perfect the kata,
make them more and
more beautiful.
The other thing I want
to say about karate
is that it's a sport in which
age, sex, and weight have
no meaning at all,
so that the tiniest
person can be just as effective
as a big hockey person.
So now let us
demonstrate some kata.
And first, I would
like to ask Alexandra
to demonstrate the beginning
kata, Taikyoku number one.
Alexandra.
FELD: Taikyoku number one.
[VOCALIZES]
[APPLAUSE]
FELD: Alexandra,
could you tell us
about the very last part
of the kata, what you did?
FELD: I am a practitioner
of the martial arts.
I bear no weapons.
I pray I will not have to use my
karate on anybody, but if I do,
I am ready.
FELD: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
FELD: Now with black belts,
the kata are more difficult.
And I would like
to now introduce
another kata called Gankaku
which Jonathan is going to do.
This is a kata which is--
"Gankaku" means
"crane on a rock."
The ancient Karatekas, the
masters, studied the animals
and they studied nature.
And in this
particular kata, it's
actually a kata which came
from studying the crane.
And I'd like you to try to
especially look at this kata
for the very end, where you
will see four one-legged crane
stances.
Jonathan.
FELD: Gankaku, crane on a rock.
[VOCALIZING WITH MOVEMENTS]
[APPLAUSE]
FELD: Now as I was
explaining, karate
is really a very defensive
art and a defensive sport.
And one of the interesting
things about the kata
is that each of
the 50 kata begins
with at least one
defensive technique
before any offensive
techniques are done.
And in this
particular kata which
we're going to show you
now, David is going to do,
it's called Bassai.
Bassai Dai is a kata in
which there are 42 moves.
And you will see that
the first eight of them
are defensive blocks.
David.
FELD:
[VOCALIZING WITH MOVEMENTS]
[APPLAUSE]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[CHEERS]
FELD: Can you hear me
without the microphone?
I'd now like to
demonstrate a black belt
kata, which is
called Tekki Shodan,
to penetrate a fortress.
It's a very strong, solid
kata, and the motions
are all in one direction.
Tekki Shodan.
[VOCALIZING WITH MOVEMENTS]
[APPLAUSE]
I forgot my notes.
Now we're going
to do [INAUDIBLE]..
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
You have a handout, which
describes a lot of information
about the physics of breaking.
And I'd like to present a
simplified discussion here.
There's a lot of interesting
physics which goes on here.
May I have the
first slide, please.
Can I have the
So the question we want to
address ourselves to now
is, we have a piece
of patio block
like this one, which
weighs 6 and 1/2 kilograms.
How is it that a
fist can actually
break a huge block like this,
let alone a pile of them?
And we can also be sure what
happens to the case of a board.
These are called 12-inch
white pine boards.
And they're used
for building houses.
Maybe I should get
the microphone.
Here.
Is this better?
Is this working?
No?
So let's begin by
having a simple model,
a [INAUDIBLE] curve.
May I have the
next slide, please?
[INAUDIBLE] turn
out all the lights.
So let's consider a block which
is the dimensions l by h by w.
This block will be
impacted in the center
by a fist, or a foot, or
some other part of the body,
producing a certain
deflection, d.
Basically, what
happens is the block
responds elastically, whether
it's a piece of concrete
or a piece of bone
or a piece of wood.
And when the forces, the
stresses inside the material
reach a high enough
point, then what happens
is that breakage occurs.
Rupture occurs.
Now if you think about
it, a simple approximation
to this situation is that
the block is like a mass,
and the mass has a spring
on it of spring constant k.
You're experts on that.
And actually, the mass is only
half the mass of the block.
And the reason for that
is, roughly speaking,
that only the middle part
of the block is moving.
The end parts of the block
are simply supported,
as shown in the diagram.
And the fist is like a body
traveling with the mass, m,
which is in the
order of a kilogram,
and a velocity v. So now, what
happens in the breaking process
from this simple point of view
is that initially, the fist
has a certain amount of
kinetic energy, 1/2 mV squared.
And it strikes the
mass-spring system.
And a collision occurs in
which momentum is conserved.
As you'll see, it's not an
energy conserving collision,
but it is a momentum
conserving collision.
And we began to talk
about momentum last time.
And what happens is that at
the end of the collision, when
the spring has
started to compress,
the mass and the spring mass
and the [INAUDIBLE] mass are
together.
And a certain
amount of energy has
been coupled into the target,
which is called k e final,
that we'll calculate
in a movement.
Now, once that final kinetic
energy is in the target,
it gets translated
to the spring,
turns into elastic
energy, 1/2 k x squared.
And when that amount
of elastic energy
is enough to break the
material, then rupture occurs.
Now, that breakage occurs when
a critical deflection, d0,
occurs.
In a moment, we'll talk about
how you figure that out.
So what I want to
first talk about
is the step of coupling
the energy from the fist
into the mass.
And it turns out that
it's very important
to be able to
think that the fact
that it is a very different
physical situation if you
have a piece of
concrete, for example.
Then the concrete-- this one
weighs 6 and 1/2 kilograms.
The fist weighs a
fraction of a kilogram.
On the other hand, when
we have a piece of board,
the board only weighs
a quarter of a kilogram
and the fist is much heavier.
It really affects the coupling
of energy considerably.
So let me just explain to you
right away that kinetic energy
is not conserved.
And I'll explain that right now.
Let's use momentum conservation.
You remember, we
talked about the fact
that the momentum was the
mass times the velocity.
Initially, we have a fist with
momentum mass times velocity.
Capital M is the
mass of the fist.
At the end, after the
collision has occurred,
we have a total object of
mass m plus M with a velocity
v. So we can easily
solve for little v
and get v equals
M over M plus m.
Now the final kinetic energy
is then the total mass
times little v squared over 2.
And if we substitute this
v, then we immediately
get that the final
kinetic energy is
equal to the initial
kinetic energy,
but reduced by a
factor M over m plus M.
So you can see that if little m,
which is the mass of the block,
is very small, then most of the
kinetic energy is coupled in.
That would be the
case of the board.
But in the case of the concrete,
where little m is huge,
then only a small fraction,
maybe 20% or 15% is coupled in.
And the rest of the energy
goes into the deformation
of the object, namely, the fist.
And we'll talk about
that a little bit later,
or the part of the body.
So finally, we derive a formula
that the initial energy is
equal to the final energy
times M plus m over M.
But then remember, we said that
that final kinetic energy was
going to become elastic energy.
And so we finally
have this equation,
that the initial
kinetic energy to be
able to break the object
is equal to this mass ratio
times the elastic energy
necessary to stress
the board to the point of
fracture, or the brick.
Next slide.
So the question is, how
can we then calculate
this critical
distance d0, which is
the amount you have to deflect
the body in order to break it?
Well, now I get to
tell you something
about mechanical engineering.
Here's the block again.
And there are two
parameters which
determine the elastic
and breaking properties
of materials.
One is Young's modulus, which
is a bulk property which
characterizes the
springiness of a material
without regard to its geometry.
And then there's some
geometrical factor which
depends upon the shape of it.
Similarly, Young's
modulus has dimensions
of Newton's per square meter.
This is force per unit area.
Similarly, sigma 0,
modulus of rupture,
is an parameter which
describes, again
in Newtons per square meter,
with a bulk material how
much stress do you have
to apply to produce
what is called a strain,
enough to rupture the material.
Now you notice that
if you think about it,
the spring constant is
related to Young's modulus,
because they both describe the
springiness of the material.
But we've got a very
funny shaped object here.
This is not shaped like
an ordinary spring.
And so it turns out that the
relationship between the spring
constant and the
elastic modulus is
given by the combination
of length, width,
and height of the block.
And you can read more
about that in the article,
if you're interested.
On the other hand, in
terms of the stress
for an object of this
shape, this stress
multiplied by the correct
geometrical factors
then gives you the force that is
necessary to break the object.
So there is a certain
amount of force necessary,
which is proportional
to the rupture modulus.
And the spring constant
is proportional
to the elastic modulus.
Now we can say that
that critical deflection
is just equal to the
spring constant times d0.
That's the force.
But we already know the force.
And so immediately, we
can calculate-- we know k,
we know F. So we calculate d0.
And it turns out to be
just the ratio of sigma
to E, the modulus of rupture
to the elastic modulus.
And then we can
calculate 1/2 k x
squared, [INAUDIBLE]
meter squared,
and we get this simple formula.
So the bottom line
is that the amount
of elastic energy necessary
to break the object
is sigma squared over 12 E
times the volume of the block.
But then remember,
that's the amount
of internal energy
needed, but there
is a coupling factors
which is calculated having
to do with momentum transfer.
And that means that the
initial kinetic energy we need
is actually equal to this
mass factor times that,
which can be much bigger.
Much more energy is
needed, especially
in the case of a heavy
object like concrete.
Next slide, please.
Next slide.
So finally, I made a
little table for you.
And this table shows
the parameters.
First of all, I put three
things here-- wood, that's
the piece of wood I showed you.
Concrete-- that's
the patio block.
And then I also put
on a piece of bone
to give you
information about that.
Now notice that
wood is the units
of newtons per square
meter times 10 to the 8th.
Wood has a value of 1.
Concrete is much different.
It's 20 times stiffer.
And notice, just for
interest, that bone
is five times
different than that.
So bone is a very
elastically still material.
Then in terms of the stresses,
the break [INAUDIBLE],,
notice that wood and concrete
aren't all that different.
But look at bone.
Look at that.
That's a factor of 50 different.
So bone is a very, very
hard material, much harder
than concrete, actually.
And in addition,
if we have time,
we'll also talk about the
effects of orientation, which
can further enhance the
advantage in breaking
the object rather
than your fist.
So now, [INAUDIBLE] calculated
the deflection distance,
the internal elastic energy,
and these other [INAUDIBLE],,
these are in your handout.
I won't probably go
over them, but just
to say that to break
a piece of wood
takes the velocity of the order
of 4 meters per second, which
a beginner could probably do.
And it takes an energy
of around 6 joules.
These numbers shouldn't
be taken too accurately,
because there's much variations
in the materials from piece
to piece.
On the other hand, it turns
out that this analysis
is a little bit simplified.
To break a piece of concrete
takes 8 or 9 meters per second.
Only an expert could do it.
And the amount of energy
is about 9 or 10 joules.
So much for the theory.
Let's get into some
experiment here.
And I think that
I will begin here
by demonstrating a hammer fist
strike of a pile of boards
over here.
As I talk, breaking is not
an essential part of karate.
And I want to explain that the
only reason that we demonstrate
these techniques is because
it's interesting physics.
And it really shows
the amount of force
that you can put
in the techniques.
I'd also like to ask you during
these breaking demonstrations
for extreme quiet.
Thank you.
This is a hammer fist.
Hyah!
[APPLAUSE]
Jonathan is going to demonstrate
a succession of techniques.
First, a knife hand strike, and
then afterwards a Yoko Gari,
which is a sidekick
to break some boards.
FELD: [VOCALIZES]
[APPLAUSE]
FELD: [INAUDIBLE]
break some concrete.
And David is going to
demonstrate first a wheel kick
and then a hammer fist
This wheel technique
is a very powerful technique.
FELD: [VOCALIZES] Hyah!
[APPLAUSE]
FELD: Now the next thing I'd
like to talk about is sparring.
Sparring is a part
of karate which
is used between experts
to be able to practice
your techniques and be
sure that they're all good,
and so forth, and so on.
And so I'd like to
ask David and Jonathan
to come out and demonstrate a
little bit of sparring, just to
[INAUDIBLE].
Just very briefly, bow.
Set.
Hashime.
[VOCALIZING]
Mate.
[APPLAUSE]
So I'd just like to conclude by
explaining to you-- let me just
show the last slide here.
Can you please give
me the next slide.
Oh, yes, let me first
show you breaking.
We actually had a strobe
movie, and I unfortunately
could not locate it.
But here is a
picture of a karateka
which is breaking a
piece of patio block
like the one you saw.
And each of these pictures
are one millisecond apart.
And you can see that
the fist is actually
in contact with the target
for about five milliseconds.
And you can see that there
are these four little dots
have been placed on the fist,
that we can use for measuring
the kinematics of the strike.
And you can see here that
even though the fist comes
in contact here, that it's
four or five milliseconds later
that the crack starts to occur.
And you can see that
the crack actually
occurs from the bottom.
And the reason why the
crack occurs from the bottom
is because most materials
are stronger in compression
than in tension.
And so it's actually this part
that actually breaks, always.
Now it's really a shame that
I couldn't find the movie,
because in the movie, you
see that the fist really
does not behave like a
piece of bone at all.
It actually behaves more
like a rubber eraser.
It completely crunches up.
And then as the
strike occurs, you
see this pulse of
muscle wave, which
is going right up
the arm, something
that was extremely unexpected.
May I have the
next slide, please.
Now here, we have
calculated by just measuring
the motion of that dot.
The displacement
during the strike--
this time scale is--
each square corresponds
to five milliseconds.
And now, by taking the rate
of change of the position,
we can get the velocity.
And then by taking the
rate of change of that,
we can get the
acceleration of the hand.
And you can see that at
the time of the strike,
the hand undergoes a huge
acceleration of 3,000
to 4,000 meters per second.
That's an enormous
acceleration or deceleration.
And it quickly comes to rest
after that, or essentially
at rest.
And may I have the
next slide, please.
Next slide, please.
[INAUDIBLE] And
here's a picture.
I wanted to show you
a picture of actually
some incomplete breaks.
And here's what happens
if you don't exactly
hit the boards in the center.
What happens is that first
of all, you can see that.
The wave motion actually
goes to the center
but it's much, much harder if
you don't hit it in the center
to be able to do that breaking.
You can see the same
thing here with concrete
as you can with the boards.
And also, it's
interesting that here, you
can see that the hand has only
moved down two or three boards.
And you can see that the boards
have been broken all the way
down to the next to last one.
And that shows that
actually, in a complicated
situation like this, the
first board actually breaks
the second and the second
one breaks the third,
and so forth, and so on.
Next, please.
Finally, let me just mention--
in your article, you can
read more about this--
that positioning is very,
very important in karate,
because the geometrical
factors that I
talked about before,
which can be optimized
to be able to protect
the bone and to have
a maximum effect on the target.
And if you look at your
handout, at the very end
of your handout, you'll
find that in fact,
if you orient your foot
correctly in a knife foot
technique like this, then it
takes 2,000 times as much force
to be able to break
this object, the bone,
as it does to be able to
break the concrete block.
So bone is quite a
remarkable object.
So in conclusion,
let me just say
that I hope that you've learned
a little bit about physics
here.
I also-- just done [INAUDIBLE].
I also hope that you learned
a little bit about karate,
and I hope that you will go away
realizing that karate is not
just something which is
used to beat people up,
but it really has many important
aesthetic applications,
as well.
Finally, I'd like to thank my
colleagues for participating
in this demonstration.
[APPLAUSE]
[INAUDIBLE]
Just take all the
broken wood, and put it
in a garbage bag for me.
I'll come and get
it, and be happy to.
And if you have a fireplace,
I'll share it with you.
I don't have a
fireplace any more.
So there's going to be
two centers of activity.
The breaking,
which occurs later,
is going to be done here.
The kata is going to go
there on that black pad
and right behind it.
So those are the two.
AUDIENCE: Kata?
FELD: Kata.
What's that?
FELD: You'll find out.
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE]
FELD: Yeah, well,
you can move around.
No big deal.
AUDIENCE: Are you
going to [INAUDIBLE]??
FELD: In some parts, yes.
In some parts, no.
You can-- yeah.
Okay, ladies and gentlemen, boys
and girls, it's time to begin.
I'd like everybody to sit down.
Settle down.
Did everybody have a good
breakfast today, this morning?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
FELD: Okay, that's important.
I'd like to make
two announcements.
First of all,
there is a handout,
which you should be getting, up
at the top of the lecture hall.
And secondly, many
students have come
to Professor Redwine and I,
and asked about the freshman
evaluation forms.
They should not be
handed in in lecture.
They should be handed in to
your recitation instructors.
So the freshman evaluation
forms in their envelopes
go to the recitation
instructors.
Now today, we have
a special lecture,
which is going to discuss the
applications of Newton's laws
to karate.
And one of the questions that
we're going to talk about
is how--
could people please settle down.
Please just-- one
of the questions
we're going to talk about
is how can a piece of bone
break a piece of concrete rather
than the reverse happening?
I mean, of course, occasionally
the reverse does happen,
but hopefully, it
won't happen today.
So we want to discuss not only
the kinematics of breaking,
the dynamics of
breaking, but we wanted
to tell you a little bit about
karate and some other things.
So in order to do that,
I've asked some colleagues
to join me.
Would you please come out?
I'd like to introduce
David Feld, Alexandra Feld,
and Jonathan Feld.
[INAUDIBLE] We are all
students of the martial arts.
And I would like to begin by
saying that our teacher was
a man named Ron McNair.
And may I have the
first slide, please.
And this lecture is dedicated
to the memory of Ron McNair.
Ron McNair was a
graduate student
in the Physics Department he
went on to become an astronaut.
He was our karate teacher.
And unfortunately he died
in the Challenger crash
several years ago.
And he was really a
very special person.
Next slide, please.
Karate is a Japanese word
which means "empty hand."
It's a form of weaponless
self-defense, which
was actually preceded
by many other forms
of weaponless fighting, which
occurred in Asia and the Orient
for more than 2,000 years.
And the origins of karate
were a mixture of religious,
philosophical, and military.
And interestingly,
karate was not
even limited to the
eastern part of the world.
Here's a picture
from the Vatican
Museum of depicting a story,
a legend which occurs 400 BC.
It's about the two
famous Greek fighters,
Damoxenos and Kruegas.
And here we see Kruegas
fighting Damoxenos
And what happened was
they fought all day long.
And neither one
could beat the other
of these two great wrestlers.
So finally, at the
end of the day,
they decided they would
decide it by a single blow.
And so first, Damoxenos
said that he would like
to strike Kruegas in the head.
And he struck a powerful blow,
but Kruegas withstood it.
And so then Kruegas
asked Damoxenos
to raise his hand,
which he raised his arm.
And here's the thing
I want to show you,
this knife hand strike,
which he then delivered.
And I won't go into
the medical details,
but suffice to say that
Kruegas won the battle,
and became the
famous Greek warrior.
So this shows that those
ancient techniques were actually
practiced in the West
as well as the East.
They occur in all parts of Asia.
They occur in Burma,
China, and India.
But what happened was that
modern karate was developed,
actually, in Okinawa in
the 17th century, when
the Japanese invaded the
island, and prevented
the feudal practices
which were then going on.
So the Okinawans,
in order to continue
doing their sport
and their fighting,
they developed weaponless
forms of fighting.
And then in early 1900s,
karate was taken from Okinawa
to Japan, where it developed
into a very formalized subject.
And today, we want to
tell you a little bit
about the study of karate.
We want to tell you a
little about the philosophy
behind karate.
We want to discuss the physical
aspects of karate, of course.
That's the most important thing.
But I don't want you
to go away, certainly,
thinking that destroying
objects is the important thing
in karate, because it's not.
Destroying objects is only a
way of gauging the effectiveness
of the techniques.
And also, I don't want you
to get the idea that karate
is a sport or an
activity which is
done to be able
to be a tough guy
or to go out and beat people up.
Karate is a very defensive art.
It's inherently defensive.
And I will explain
that more as we go on.
So in this lecture, what
we're going to talk about
is, first of all, some
of the basic techniques.
And then we're going to
talk about the kata, which
are perhaps the most beautiful
and interesting part of karate,
to me, at least.
Then we're going to discuss the
theory and experimental aspects
of breaking of objects.
And then we'll discuss a
few other things, as well.
So I would like to
now begin by asking
David and Jonathan to
come out and demonstrate
some basic techniques.
So let us now begin
by demonstrating
the most basic
technique in all karate,
the front forward
punch, Seiken Zuki.
Now this is a good example of
a typical karate technique.
It's very, very different
from the Western sports
which are practiced.
In Western sports, the
first thing you learn
is about follow-through in
baseball, or golf, or boxing.
But in karate, there is no
follow through whatsoever
on almost every technique.
Instead, there is focus.
This technique is delivered
with a high velocity.
It terminates in a
very short period,
right inside the target.
And the focus is very
important in imparting
the maximum amount of momentum
and force to the target.
And the ancient orientals
who studied this
had no notion of Newton's
laws, but they still
developed techniques
which, when we study them
by modern methods, we can see
that these techniques really
make nearly optimal
use of the human body.
So let's demonstrate
that in a faster method.
FELD: [YELLS]
FELD: Okay, now
karate techniques
are also very highly
prescribed, very formalized.
For example, there are
many, many techniques
in many parts of the
hands, feet, head, elbows.
Many parts of the body can be
used to deliver techniques.
Even with the hand, there
are many, many parts
of the hand which can be used
to deliver karate techniques,
but each one is done in
a very prescribed way.
So for example, you can also
do a front forward punch
to the face rather than
to the solar plexus.
Demonstrate that, please.
FELD: [YELLS]
FELD: Just as we have
strikes in karate,
we also have ways of defending
ourselves against strikes.
And now, we'll have
a series of Jonathan
will demonstrate
some blocks, which
are used to defend the strikes.
Go ahead.
FELD: [VOCALIZING]
FELD: So this is
a mid-body block.
And you can see that
here, the principle is not
to meet it with force on
force, but instead to provide
a certain amount of transverse
force and transverse
momentum, which will deflect
the oncoming technique,
and render it ineffective.
There are many, many
other techniques,
and Jonathan will now
demonstrate a hammer fist
strike, which is another type.
And David will show how
you defend against that.
FELD: [VOCALIZING]
FELD: As I said, other parts of
the body can be used, as well.
And let us just
demonstrate to you
now one kick, the
side kick, which
is a very powerful
technique, the Yoko
Gari to the solar plexus.
Now let me just show
you here for a moment.
Notice that here again,
this is a technique
in which the foot is knifed in
a position in which the very
narrowest surface area is
presented to the target.
The toes are curled so that
they're out of the way,
and not in danger of being
broken off in the technique.
And this can deliver a great
deal of energy and momentum,
as we'll talk about in a moment.
Now do it at full speed.
FELD: [YELLS]
FELD: Thank you very much.
Now I'd like to have
the next slide, please.
And now, I want to show
you some measurements
that we've taken of
various karate techniques
so that we could get some
feeling of how much energy is
available in a karate strike.
And here's a picture of--
this actually is a set of strobe
photos taken in Doc Edgerton's
lab, of a Seiken Zuki, a
front forward punch, taken
at exposures with
intervals of one
millisecond from one another.
And then, by just taking
the location of the fist,
and plotting this as
a function of time
or plotting it as a
function of distance,
we can measure
the velocity which
is developed in this technique.
And here you can
see, for example,
this particular
technique had a velocity
of about 7 meters per
second at a distance which
was about 85% percent
of the distance
through the technique, and
maybe one or two centimeters
inside the target,
which is just about
right for karate techniques.
So here, you have
a typical number,
like maybe 10 meters per second
as the amount of velocity
you can develop in
a karate technique.
And if you consider a hand,
for example, the mass of a hand
is a little bit less
than a kilogram,
typically, maybe
7/10 of a kilogram.
And so if we figure out the
amount of kinetic energy
which is available
there, we know
it's 1/2 mass times
the velocity squared.
Let's take the velocity
as 10 meters per second.
So 10 squared is 100 times
1 is 100 divided by 2 is 50.
So typically, there's
about 50 joules of energy
available in a karate technique
when delivered by an expert.
Can I have the
next slide, please.
Now here, we have a
hammer fist strike,
in this case breaking some wood.
And here again, we've
studied the motion here.
And over a period of
100 or 150 milliseconds,
which is pretty slow--
this is a slow technique,
but a powerful one--
something like velocity
of 12 meters per second
was developed.
Next, please.
And here is a list of
various techniques--
the Seiken Zuki, the hammer fist
strike, a knife hand strike,
various kicks.
And you can see in each case
that the peak speeds, which
are reached right inside
the target in each case
when delivered by an
expert, are of the order
of 10 meters per second.
And there's some
more information
about that in your
handout in case
you're interested in
more facts about that.
May I have the
next slide, please?
Fine, enough for the
slides right now.
So now, I would like
to go on to what
I think is the most interesting
part of karate, the kata.
And the kata are very
similar to special types
of ballet sequences
of classical ballet.
In the kata, the karateka
goes through a series
of motions in which he or
she is protecting herself
against a series of
imaginary attackers.
And the moves are highly
prescribed, highly formalized.
Kata are something
in which you're only
competing against yourself.
You strive for perfection,
just as you would in ballet.
It's really a way of trying
to do beautiful things
with your body.
And some of the kata
are quite beautiful.
There are about
50 of these kata.
And interestingly,
every one of them
begins with at least
one defensive technique.
And that's typical of karate.
Karate is really
a defensive art.
It is not an aggressive
kind of an art.
So let me now ask
Alexandra if she
will demonstrate the beginner
kata, Taikyoku number one.
Alexandra, would
you please do that.
FELD: Taikyoku number one.
[VOCALIZES]
[APPLAUSE]
FELD: Alexandra, could
you please tell us
about the very last thing
that you did in the kata.
FELD: I am a practitioner
of the martial arts.
I bear no weapons.
I pray I will not have to use my
karate on anybody, but if I do,
I am ready.
FELD: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
As you can see, there are many
symbolic gestures in karate.
And I also want to
mention that karate
is one of those sports
where age, sex, weight,
height are really no barrier.
And in karate tournaments, the
littlest people and the biggest
people can all compete
together depending
upon their belt color,
rather than upon their age.
Now I'd like to get into
some more advanced kata.
And I'd like to now
show you a kata.
Jonathan will show
us a card which
is called Gankaku, which
means "crane on a rock."
The ancient Asian karate
masters studied nature
and studied animals to
understand much about how
to optimize techniques.
And this particular
kata was actually
based on the study of the crane.
And I'd like you to look
very, very carefully
at the end of this kata.
See if you can see
the four stances
of the one-legged crane.
Jonathan.
FELD: Gankaku, crane on a rock.
[VOCALIZING]
[APPLAUSE]
FELD: Thanks, John.
Now we'd like to now
demonstrate another technique.
David is going to demonstrate a
kata called Bassai, Bassai Dai.
And Bassai is a kata
which really demonstrates,
once again, the defensive
nature of karate.
This is a very powerful
kata, and yet you
will notice that of the
42 moves of the kata,
the first eight of them are
purely defensive techniques,
are purely blocks.
So before any kind of
counter-attacks occur,
the karateka makes an attempt
to avoid any kind of conflict
by making eight blocks.
And only after
blocking his opponents,
and finding that he
has no way out does
he find that he has
to go on the attack.
David.
FELD: [VOCALIZING]
[APPLAUSE]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[CHEERS]
[INAUDIBLE] These are
difficult to get on.
I'd like to now demonstrate
a kata called Tekki.
And "tekki" means "to
penetrate a fortress."
It's a linear kata.
It's a very strong
kata, and it's again
a very defensive kata.
Tekki Shodan.
[VOCALIZES]
[APPLAUSE]
I'd like to now
talk a little bit
about the physics of breaking.
And in all the excitement,
I forgot my notes.
Let me go and get them.
So let's discuss how
it is concrete patio
blocks like this certainly
seem like massive objects.
And it's hard to believe
that a person can
break one or many of them.
And yet it's possible,
and we should understand
from simple point of
view of Newton's laws
could be brought about.
May I have the
first slide, please?
It's just [INAUDIBLE] lights.
Leave that slide.
So basically, the
problem of breaking
is a problem of wave motion,
exciting waves in a block.
And a block is really considered
to be like a violin strings.
And if you're interested
in some of the details,
you can read the handout, which
discusses this in some detail.
But I'd like to present today
a sort of simplified picture
in which we consider it instead
a problem of momentum transfer.
And so basically,
here's the idea.
We have a fist that's impacting
on a piece of concrete
or so forth and so on.
And we want to understand
exactly how objects break,
what it takes to break them.
May I have next slide, please.
So here we have
our board or block
with dimensions l, h and w.
And the block
undergoes a deflection
when struck with the fist or
with a foot, as shown here.
And basically, as we'll
explain in a moment, when
that inflection reaches
a critical distance,
the object breaks.
But I'm getting
ahead of myself here.
The first thing
is that the object
is an object which is elastic.
You can think about it--
even a piece of concrete
has a certain amount
of elasticity in it.
That can be seen, for example,
by taking a piece of concrete
and halving it with a
hammer, and noticing that it
can support [INAUDIBLE].
So it does have
some elastic nature.
So does bone, And so
does every property.
And so in a sense, you
can think of this problem
as really like the problem
of a mass on a spring--
that really, this
concrete block can
be thought of as
a mass of concrete
on a spring of constant k.
And actually, the mass, the
effective mass is only 1/2
the mass of the object.
And the reason why is roughly
because only the middle
of the object moves.
The ends are simply
supported, as shown here.
And they don't participate
in the motion at all.
So it turns out that if
you study the theory,
that only half of
the mass comes in.
And we have to figure out
what the spring constant is
in terms of the elastic nature
of the object and its geometry.
So basically, we
can sort of model
this problem as a
problem of having
a mass, a fist or a foot, a mass
capital M and velocity capital
V, which is impacting on the
spring and compressing it.
So here, we have drawn
the picture of that.
And I'd like to point out
three phases of the process
according to the
simplified picture.
In the first phase,
we have the fist
with an initial kinetic
energy, 1/2 MV squared,
which is just about to make
an impact on the block.
In the second phase,
before the spring has
had a chance to compress
but after the collision has
occurred, we have a situation
where the two masses are
essentially stuck
together in contact,
and the mass system now is
moving with a velocity V,
giving a final kinetic
energy [INAUDIBLE]
M plus m times little v squared.
Now that system can
then convert this energy
into elastic energy,
1/2 kx squared.
And when the compression
is sufficient to compress
the object to a distance
d0, a critical distance
that we'll talk
about in a moment,
then that elastic energy
will break the object.
Now I want to point
out to you [INAUDIBLE]
studying momentum
in the last lecture.
And I want to point
out to you that this
is a process in which kinetic
energy is actually not
conserved.
And I'll show you
that very simply.
The kinetic energy which is
available here cannot all go
into the object.
And that really depends,
to a certain amount,
on the nature of the object.
It really depends on
the ratio of the masses,
as I'll show you now.
But basically, if you have
a piece of wood like this,
which is a mass of maybe
a quarter of a kilogram--
this is 1 inch white pine--
and you strike it
like this, then
the fist is much more
massive than the wood.
And that, as you will see, gives
very effective energy transfer.
But on the other hand, a
heavy thing like this-- this
is a concrete patio block
made of number three cement,
and it has a weight of 6.5 kg.
And so because the hand
is relatively light
compared to that, the amount
of energy which is transferred
is very small.
I want you to see that.
The way it works is
this-- let's just use
the conservation of momentum.
The initial momentum--
you remember that momentum
is just the product of
mass times velocity.
So the initial momentum that
we have is just the mass times
the velocity of this object.
But then this is still, so it
has no momentum, [INAUDIBLE]..
But afterwards, when the two
objects are stuck together
here, then we have
a momentum which
is the sum of the masses
times the final velocity.
And of course, it's
very easy, then,
to find what that
final velocity is.
And it's just given by d
times capital M over M plus m.
Now the final kinetic energy is
just 1/2 times the total mass,
M plus m, times
little v squared.
If you then substituted
little v squared,
you find something
very interesting.
And that is that in terms of
the initial kinetic energy,
1/2 capital M capital V squared,
the final kinetic energy
is less.
The final kinetic energy is less
than the initial kinetic energy
by the ratio of the
mass of the hand
to the sum of the masses
of the hand and the board,
which shows that if
you have a heavy object
that you're striking
with, this fraction will
be a very small
fraction, indicating
that very little of the
available kinetic energy
can actually be
transferred to the object.
Now also notice
that we can get--
we said that the final
kinetic energy immediately
could be converted
into elastic energy.
And so therefore, I can solve
for the initial kinetic energy
setting it equal
to M plus M over m
times the final kinetic
energy, and then
saying that the final
kinetic energy then becomes
the elastic energy, and
get this very basic formula
that the initial kinetic energy
needed to break this object
is equal to whatever that
elastic energy turns out
to be multiplied by a
number bigger than 1,
which depends upon the momentum
transfer between the fist
and the object.
Can I have the
next slide, please.
So now what we have to do
is we have to figure out
what is the spring constant
of this effective system,
and what is the critical
distance for breaking.
Now here, we have
to talk a little bit
about mechanical engineering.
There are two properties which
actually describe the behavior
of a material like this.
The first one is
called Young's modulus,
and it describes the
elasticity of the object.
And the next one is called
the modulus of rupture.
And it is a measure
of how much force
or how much stress is
necessary to break the object.
And these are
numbers which really
are independent of the
shape of the object.
They just depend
upon the material.
So Young's modulus, E, has units
of newtons per square meter.
And the rupture modulus, sigma
0, also has the same units.
And this one, then, has to do
with what kind of springiness
the object has.
And this one is
how much resilience
it has to-- how much forces
are set up before it breaks.
Now, you have to put in
the geometry of the object
to be able to get the
quantities that you really need.
So if you take this
Young's modulus,
the elasticity parameter,
and you multiply it
by the appropriate
shape factor, which
is a combination of
the length, width,
and height of the
object, then you find out
the spring constant
is just this Young's
modulus times that combination.
Similarly, for this
particular kind of a geometry,
when broken at
the top like this,
the amount of force
necessary to break the object
is just given by the modulus
of rupture multiplied
by these same parameters.
Now, once we have
this formula for F
and we have this
formula for k, we
can easily find d0, the
critical deflection,
by simply saying
F0, which we know,
and k that we know times d0.
And that immediately
gives us that d0
is equal to some
combination of dimensions
times the modulus of rupture
divided by the elastic modulus.
And then we can say that
the elastic energy required
to break the block is
just 1/2 k d0 squared.
And that turns out to be
this very simple formula--
sigma 0 squared over 12E times
the volume of the object.
Now, remember that
we said before
that this is the internal energy
needed to break the object.
But on the other hand, in
terms of the initial energy
available in the fist,
we have to multiply
this factor of M plus m over
M. So that's the basic idea
of this simple picture.
May I have the
next slide, please.
I just made a little table
here to summarize for you
what these parameters
are for three things--
first of all, the wood
I just showed you,
the concrete that I showed
you and then some bone.
So first of all, the springiness
parameter, the Young's modulus,
this is in units of 10 to the
8th newtons per square meter.
For wood, it's
about 1, but you can
see that it's 50 times
bigger for concrete,
maybe not 50 times bigger,
but 20 times bigger.
And so you can see that
concrete is a much stiffer
material than wood, which
makes a lot of sense.
But interestingly, you can see
that bone is maybe five or four
times stiffer than any.
So bone is an extremely
stiff material Furthermore,
in terms of the
modulus of rupture,
you can see that wood and
concrete aren't that different,
but the bone is enormously high.
That means it takes
much more stress
to be able to break
a piece of bone.
So now these are
some of the clues
that we're beginning to see,
as to why it's so difficult,
why it's so easy to break
materials with hands and feet.
And now here's some of the
critical breaking parameters.
I don't want to go into
them in great detail.
But let me just go to some
interesting numbers here.
First of all, to
break a piece of wood
requires kinetic energy
according to this model
of about 6 joules.
And remember, we estimated that
a good, expert karate strike,
there might be something
like 50 joules available,
so there's plenty
of energy there.
And notice that
according to this model,
it takes about 9 joules to break
that piece of concrete, which
is still much less
than we have available,
so it should be doable.
I also want to point out
that this model is really not
terribly accurate.
And if you read
your handout, you'll
find a more accurate model.
And in particular, the
thing which is worse
is about this model
is that it predicts
that the velocities available
to be able to break wood
and concrete are very close.
It turns out that with a
more careful calculation
that this is about right.
It takes about 4 meters
per second to break wood,
which means that even
a beginner can easily
break a piece of wood.
But it actually
takes more like 8
or 9 meters per second
of initial velocity
to be able to break
a piece of concrete.
So that concludes the
theoretical part of this.
And now let's do some
experiments to actually
be able to demonstrate this.
And I would first like to begin
by demonstrating a hammer fist
strike of this pile
of boards over here.
And let me begin by
again emphasizing
that breaking is not really
an inherent part of karate.
It's not usually practiced
in practice session.
It's really not important.
It's very showy, but the
only reason that we do it
is because we want
to be able to gauge
the effectiveness
of the techniques,
and also because it demonstrates
a very nice piece of physics
from our point of view.
The other thing
is that these are
rather difficult techniques.
And so I would really like
to ask for complete silence
during the demonstration
that we're going to give you.
So this is going
to be a hammer fist
strike of a pile of boards.
Hyah!
[APPLAUSE]
Now I'd like to demonstrate
some more intricate techniques.
Johnathan is now going to
demonstrate a knife hand
strike and a Yoko
Gari, which he's
going to break some
materials with his hand
and then with his fist.
John.
FELD: [VOCALIZING]
[VOCALIZING]
[APPLAUSE]
FELD: Now David is going
to demonstrate first
breaking some boards
with a wheel kick, which
is a very powerful technique
with the heel of his foot,
and then some of
these concrete patio
blocks afterwards with
a hammer fist strike.
FELD: Hyah!
Hyah!
[APPLAUSE]
FELD: Now, another
part of karate,
which is part of the
practice is fighting,
sparring, or [INAUDIBLE].
And we'd like to just give you
a little demonstration of that
now, just to give you a
feeling for how it works.
[INAUDIBLE] set.
Hashime.
FELD: [VOCALIZING]
FELD: [INAUDIBLE]
[APPLAUSE]
Can I have the
next slide, please.
I'd love to show you some still
photographs of the strobe movie
we took some time ago to
study in more detail what
happens when a fist breaks
a concrete patio block.
You can see the concrete
patio block here.
These photos were actually taken
in Doc Edgerton's strobe lab.
And here, you can see that
the fist has four [INAUDIBLE]
on it, so that we can
study the kinetic motion
of different parts of the fist.
And each of these frames--
one, two, three,
four, five, six--
are taken one millisecond apart.
And what you can see here is--
I'm very sorry I don't
have the movie up,
because the movie
is really much more
dramatic than these stills.
But what you see
here is that the fist
is in contact with the
block for 5 milliseconds.
Then you can sort
of see by this point
here that there is an enormous
deformation of the fist.
And in the movie,
you can actually
see that the fist really
doesn't behave like a bone.
It really behaves more
like a blob of putty,
and it completely distorts.
And then as the
strike occurs, you
can see this wave of muscle
pulse go right up the arm.
It's really quite dramatic.
The other interesting
thing is you
can see that the fist was in
contact with the concrete here,
but it's only 4
milliseconds later
that the crack actually begins.
And also, you can
see that the block
cracks from the bottom up.
And the reason for that
is because most materials
are stronger under compression
than under tension.
And so what happens is that
the concrete breaks here
rather than there.
May I have the
next slide, please?
Now one of those
dots, I don't know
remember what dot it was,
we marked the displacement
as a function of time out of
all of these different-- of each
of these dots.
And from there, we can
take the derivative.
We can study the rate
of change of that
and get an idea of the
velocity of the hand.
And you can see
here that the hand
started at a velocity
of 12 meters per second.
And it gradually
decelerated to 0.
And you can actually study
the acceleration here
by simply taking the
derivative of that.
And you're experts in that.
And you can see that the
amount of deceleration which
occurs here is quite enormous--
around 3,000 meters per second
squared, which is really
an enormous stress that
the hand must undergo
when decelerating so rapidly.
May I have the
next slide, please.
I didn't fully break the
stack of boards today.
And in this picture, I also
didn't break a stack of boards.
And probably the
reason is the same.
Here you can see
what happens when
you hit the boards not
in the exact center,
but off to the side slightly.
And you can see
that what happens
is a kind of wave of destruction
of broken boards occurs.
And you can see it's trying
to move towards the center.
But you can see that the bottom
one didn't actually break.
And there's another interesting
thing that you can see here,
and that is that even though
the hand has only moved two
or three boards down--
that's 2 or 3 inches--
you can see that the boards are
broken well, well below that,
maybe 8 or 10 inches below.
And that shows that actually
what's happening here
is that the first
board is breaking
the second, and the second the
third, and so forth and so on.
And then you can see the same
thing occurs in concrete.
And here again, these blocks
were not hit in the center.
But it hit off center, and
that produced a situation
where the crack
propagated inward,
but then it was not possible to
break both boards [INAUDIBLE]..
Can I have the
next slide, please.
And finally, I'm not
going to have time
to go into all the
details to this,
but I just want to say that, in
addition to the rather enormous
differences in the
elastic properties of bone
and the rupture
properties of bone
compared to those of
building materials,
there is also a
fact of positioning,
which is very, very important,
the geometrical factor.
And this is very
intuitive, of course.
If you hit this
target flat-footed,
you're likely to hurt yourself
a lot more than if you
hit with a knife foot.
And you can actually include
the geometrical effects
in the analysis along
with the bulk properties,
the Young's modulus and
the modulus of rupture.
And if you do that, if you
look at the very, very end
of the handout that
we have, you will
see that in fact, a properly
positioned foot like this,
actually, the force
necessary to break this bone
is about 2,000 times
greater than the force
necessary to break
the concrete block.
You can see it's an
enormous differential.
So now, I would like to--
first of all, in
conclusion, I'd like
to thank my colleagues
for participating
in this demonstration.
[APPLAUSE]